chris manjapra is a professor of history
at tufts university with expertise in
the history of colonialism and empire
well he joins us from trio massachusetts
uh welcome to the program what do you
make of the pomp and ceremony that we've
witnessed so far with the queen's
passing
well you know thanks for having me first
of all and i've been struck by the the
mania in uh the media over you know
covering the death of the queen in this
way
yes you know mourning is is definitely
appropriate when there's someone who
passes in a family and someone who's
very well known but in discussing and
talking about the the glorification of
the queen as we're seeing in her passing
what aren't we talking about you know
that's kind of the question that i'm
left with specifically the violence that
has been committed in the name of this
queen really over the course of her
whole reign that's what really worries
me that that story is not being told and
it's not in the media
so why is the legacy of imperialism
still so important today then do you
think
well um you know there are many people
in our world in fact the majority of our
world
who understand uh at a family level um
and at national levels
why imperial violence matters um when we
look at how decolonization ended yes it
ended in the time in which queen
elizabeth came to the throne in the 19th
it began in the 1950s when she came to
the throne we've been in a period of
decolonization from the 1950s onwards
but during the same period we've seen
ongoing injustice we've seen under the
rule of queen elizabeth we've seen the
violence
and the plunder and the massacres that
took place in malaya
in yemen in aden
in kenya the mao mao uprising we've seen
underdevelopment that has been made
systemic
in places like the caribbean and africa
and even south asia and you know in my
own research i just determined i
discovered that it took until 2015
for the british government to in fact
stop paying
its debt that it took out about 180
years ago for slave owner reparations
and this was being carried on again in
the name of the queen so
the the past of colonialism continues to
live on today and partly it's because we
continue to tell the story of the empire
and not appreciate the pain and the
suffering and the plunder of those who
have been colonized by that empire that
that that's something that we need to
make some space for i think
some people might say that all the
atrocities of imperialism were in the
past and so it's time to move forward
now time to move on how would you
respond to that
well i think it's you know convenient to
um think of atrocities as uh kind of
linked to a particular date in the past
and we're able to do that if we don't
recognize the way that in fact
atrocities continue through time
when you look at colonialism the story
is really not about an end followed by a
beginning of uh you know a commonwealth
or beginning of
the post-colonial era it really is about
injustices that have been papered over
have not been
recognized amends has not been paid
reparation has not been made and because
of that in fact this violence has become
structural it determines the
international relationship between
britain and its post colonies and it
determines the national experience of
people in the post-colonial world today
um the suffering in the post-colonial
world and that has a lot to do with
unsolved business
and that also unsolved businesses is
very conveniently being swept under the
rug and this kind of you know overt
display of sadness and mourning you know
i think of it another way which is to
say why is it so easy to feel sorrow uh
and to feel mourning for the death of
queen elizabeth ii but it's so hard to
feel remorse
for the death and the suffering of
millions of people who have suffered in
the name
of queen elizabeth ii i think that's
actually a very important question to
sit with
given what you say then where does all
this leave the
future of the commonwealth
well
you know back in november 2021 i think
we got a clue to that story when
barbados took the step to leave the
commonwealth and to declaw declare
its status as a republic there are eight
remaining
commonwealth nations in the caribbean uh
i would imagine that we could expect to
see others leaving in the coming years
and i would certainly welcome that as a
path towards truth um and
acknowledgement of the past but you know
as we're having these this thraldom um
internationally really we're
experiencing it in britain but i'm here
in the united states we see it all over
our media today as a thraldom um of
concern and and and sorrow and and
sadness
around the death of queen elizabeth ii
you know i'm in many ways wondering when
do we get to talk about the death of the
monarchy uh and i think that in fact
would be something to look forward to in
this 21st century
chris manjappa professor of history at
tufts university thank you very much
indeed for joining us here on al jazeera
thank you very much